el presidente de Bolivia Luis Arce firmó
la ley de censo de población que
finalmente se realizará el 23 de marzo
de 2024 el anuncio llegó tras semanas de
protestas para reclamar su realización
que dejaron Al menos cuatro muertos
el censo se llevará a cabo el 23 de
marzo del 2024 porque es con todos
ustedes Con quienes Me comprometí a
mantenernos firme en la defensa de lo
que técnicamente es correcto el gobierno
habría fijado inicialmente el censo para
2022 luego lo postergó para octubre de
2024 argumentando problemas técnicos en
respuesta Santa Cruz Región del este del
país y bastión de la oposición de
derecha realizó una huelga de 36 días
para reclamar que el censo fuera en 2023
ya que podría cambiar su representación
parlamentaria de Cara a las elecciones
generales del 2025 la protesta concluyó
la semana pasada cuando el gobierno y la
oposición alcanzaron un acuerdo que
selló el calendario Para marzo de 2024
Sin embargo la decisión generó fracturas
dentro del oficialismo el expresidente
Evo Morales acusó al gobierno de haber
cedido a las presiones de la derecha la
ley que se aprobó en las cámaras de
diputados y senadores no es una ley de
la derecha es una ley propuesta por
nuestros diputados del más ipcp que no
vulnera competencias de nivel central
del Estado según el gobierno la nueva
fecha del censo permitirá la
distribución de recursos económicos y la
reasignación de escaños para antes de
las elecciones generales de 2025